yo what's up guys welcome to another hd
video brought to you by mkbhd and today
as you can see this is going to be an
unboxing video and this is an ifrog's
unboxing video this is um what was i
actually got two packages in the mail
today but i do dedicate a video one for
the unboxing the unboxing and first
impressions for every product that i get
so this is the uh the unboxing of the
eye frogs um air pollution d33 earphones
they are noise isolating earphones
i will obviously have a huge full review
video of everything i get so i thank you
i frogs for sending this out to me and
uh so here we go with the unboxing i
don't want to uh cut anything in here i
just want to
get this open so here we go
see if we can just take open the top
and i guess i can't wait to get that
microphone review to you because that is
also a great microphone uh that was sent
to me so i really want to get that
review video out anyway here we go
so here's a little uh little note with
the shipping information and everything
here are the headphones themselves and
you know just bubble wrap inside nothing
special so they can put that off to the
side so here is the uh the actual
ifrog's earphones now first thing you'll
see is uh that it's just it does say
there are noise isolating earbuds it
says at the bottom have little travel
case which is very cool because i do
like cases that come with travel cases
so you don't really lose them
so that's basically all that's in the
box you will also have uh the headphones
which do look pretty nice i like the way
they're shaped the color they're black
that's cool
and also you'll get uh three different
sizes of your phone so the ones that are
on are are medium sized i keep going off
camera sorry
they're medium sized they are larger
size and smaller size so i'm actually
going to try to get in this box here it
does look easy uh yeah it is actually
so if we just pull up the bottom uh here
is the ifrog's carrying case a little
paper here
it is a hard case and zipper
that's cool that's very cool
it's hard on the inside but it is it is
kind of flexible so that's cool i like
this carrying case it's very good
accessory i like companies that include
the small things that just make the
product easier to use so that's cool
uh what else can we get
and yeah we can get to the headphones
here we go
so we have the the earbuds that come
with the uh
that come with the earphone that aren't
actually on the headphones so the you
know you have the larger ones the
smaller ones and the ones that are still
on now we have a little piece of paper
in here
that looks like they have the rest of it
wow
there we go all right here we go pull
the rest of the package out pull the
earbuds themselves out of the package
and here we go so here's the earbuds
they just say noise isolating and clean
deep tone now i really sorry i keep
going off i really like headphones with
deep bass so i like um i like headphones
that are like in here then i give the
nice clean rich deep sound uh this so
i'm just going to take this out of here
they just have all the specs on the back
so a nine millimeter driver size uh the
impedance frequency magnet type all that
stuff 3.5 millimeter
uh so we just take this part off and we
can obviously read all the specs of it
later but um you can always visit the
link in the description to get the full
specs the price it's ifrogs.com it's a
great great site
and they do have a lot of also iphone
accessories and stuff so here we go with
the first impressions they they look
nice they're uh
wow this is not focusing at all but yeah
they actually have this kind of slant
little thing going on and they do look
like they're going to provide a deep
some good base
so um
yeah the color i like the color if you
can see that on the side it says eye
frogs this is right here and i do say
that's the leftier um 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack which means i'll be able
to use it for my laptop you'll be able
to use it for your cell phone if it has
a 3.5 so that's cool
so yeah guys that's what came in the box
with the d33s you'll be able to check it
out more at the link in the description
of course um stay tuned for the
microphone review this is the first
impressions and unboxing of the ifrog
z33s stay tuned for a full review i'll
be using these comparing them to my
current headphones um comparing
contrasting stuff like that so yeah stay
tuned for my for a full review video
stay tuned for the uh microphone review
and yeah so thanks again ifrogs and uh
thanks for watching this video from
mkbhd hope you liked it and uh stay
tuned for the full review peace